hello it's Hank John and I just finished
a nineteen city tour and on that tour
every day we did a short 25 minute dear
Hank and John live show and most of
those shows did not get recorded but in
the places where it was easy and we had
time to set it up we recorded I have
just finished editing together a bunch
of clips from the ones that we recorded
into a full-length podcast for you today
so as we go through you will notice that
the audio quality will change a bit from
place to place and sometimes it's bad
just it sounds bad I apologize for that
also if you like live podcasts and like
the idea of that or you just love
podcasts in general John and I have
teamed up with the people from welcome
to night Vale and the McElroy brothers
to create an event
December 9th and 10th and Seattle there
will be live recordings of podcasts
panels discussing this medium weird
podcast mashups games about performances
and more we are going to have many cool
people we'll have people from the bright
sessions Kevin T Porter of the Gilmore
guys Paul Bay of the black tapes Roman
Mars Franchesca Ramsey rod and Karen
Mauro the orbiting human circus sleep
with me Aparna nancherla live podcasts
will include lore dear Hank and John
Harry Potter and the sacred texts
criminal my brother my brother and me
the the adventure zone zone Sawbones
Alice's and Dead bad with money and more
if you're interested in joining our
creator chat which is just like an
opportunity to talk with creators or our
signing lotteries that closes November
12th so if you're looking to get your
tickets you should probably do it pretty
soon I know that first time events are a
bit risky to go to you don't know
exactly what you're gonna get
nobody's been to it yet but they are
also usually the most surprising
inspiring and special of all the events
that I do and then I go to I think we've
put together a really amazing event here
and I would be honored if you put your
faith in us and as an additional benefit
if you use the coupon code dear Hank as
you're checking out for your $100 in
real person attendance to pod con you
will get 10% off so thank you for that
you could use the coupon code dear John
if you want to but I will be watching so
I don't know why you would you can also
attend the show digitally for $30 you
can get all of the audio recorded at the
event delivered right into your podcast
app and now let us go into the live
shows
we were gonna start with some bits we
did in st. Paul Minnesota which is not
the same thing as Minneapolis it's a
comedy podcast where two brothers answer
you questions give you Denise advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon how you doing
John oh yeah good I mean it's a dance
man I came out here at the very first
thing I said I don't think you heard me
say it the very first thing I said was
it's so nice to be here in Minneapolis
well you didn't make yourself a little
hole there yeah so I've been trying to
work my way back with the crowd the
whole time
you know I they seem pretty forgiving
Minnesotans are notoriously grudge
holders oh yeah
I've heard that you've heard of you've
heard of Minnesota mean yeah you don't
like our ice cream I went to Izzie the
ice cream place oh my god
what is it Oh what I mean we have good
ice cream in Montana but I got the
salted caramel and it's like a fresh
fresh plate I was like do they have a
herd of cows they're just in the back
are our bus driver Brock who's become a
great friend of ours or at least we like
him a lot he we had a rest stop
somewhere in Wisconsin I don't recall
where forgive me and he he he opened up
the bus door and he looked back at Hank
and he said why are you always eating I
mean it's true and then Hank was like I
do other things and I looked at him I
was like yeah wall eating
I'm a true multitasker John do you want
to hear some questions for our for my
listeners desperately this next question
comes from our listener cat who asked
dear Hank and John which are closer
related centaurs and humans because the
upper half part centaurs and horses
because of the lower half part or
centaurs and Dragons because they both
have six limbs this is an amazing point
it's a great question on they're all
terrestrial vertebrates have the exact
same body plan you got the head and you
got the two limbs on top of the two
limbs on bottom yeah and then you got
like the butt part in between the bottom
limbs and it's all organized the same
way except dragons and centaurs who are
just like extra - and Goro from Mortal
Kombat and the avatar people yeah so the
obvious answer is that it's it's
centaurs and drag yes much more closely
related oh so much more yeah like it's
like all like a whole sort of like oh
wow that like they need their own yeah
like like our Linnaeus would be like we
need to create a new thingy it's a hole
what are we thinking they're in a new
domain I think the only thing that I
just call the thingy okay the only thing
that I'd note though is that I think
centaurs and Dragons must have evolved
from ants this question comes from
Efrain who says this is the question in
its entirety Hank Dear John and Hank I'm
confused about Batman its Batman here
oh yeah Batman is here I saw several
Batman so he's not a bat man he's not
actually like spider-man is kind of like
has spider things that happen in spider
DNA yeah like proper superhero
yeah is that the case like are there
other superhero man well he's not part
water he is part water like everybody
he's largely water but more to the point
he's part fish no but yeah Batman is yet
just to be very clear if you're confused
about Batman he doesn't have any bat DNA
doesn't have wings he it's just a man
who dresses up in a suit and he's got a
guy like Halloween every day or every
night I guess or whenever crime-fighting
happens he doesn't and he like he's not
like Superman where he can change
clothes real fast he has to go home to
change which seem to look a little bit
of a limitation just to be clear he's
not a superhero IIIi don't want to make
too much of a point of this but this is
incredibly important um
Batman is not a superhero Batman is a
metaphor for our worship of individual
wealth like Batman is a metaphor for the
what we think billionaires are and can
be
okay he's like Batman is Elon Musk I'm
sure is here tonight it's thank you for
being here there's I know you have a lot
of important problems to solve but there
is a third-tier English soccer team I
would like to introduce you to my god do
they need money
Batman is he really I've said this
before but he really is just a rich
person with an affinity for bats and I I
get why Batman is important and like in
a crucial part of the cultural
conversation but I think we have to
remember that like what makes Batman
interesting is that Batman is
complicated like in a way Superman
frankly isn't Superman's just wish
fulfillment this next question comes
from we're gonna have to move on from
Leisha who asks because this is a very
important question how do we best
promote our guinea pigs Instagram oh
well let's stop everything I have the
username well the first off good job
putting to use questions oh sorry
good job putting the username in the
question that's your first step I'll
just go to events go to every book event
you can just put that question in every
time with the guinea pigs and slowly
it'll happen so it's Pig
in the letter n and then - and plop
diggin plop and you have you had one
follower earlier today you have two now
because I followed you when I was
backstage your way it seems a little bit
like this is a new endeavor there are
three photos so but there was I believe
a Batman and Superman guinea pig because
it is Halloween and it seemed that that
was what their their costumes were this
year and I don't want to take it to a
dark place but like take it to a dark
place if you want a water you're gonna
work and work and work and build up this
this guinea pigs Instagram / like say
two years just gotta be just be thinking
- Atari lived for 200 years I don't know
if you've considered having a celebrity
Instagram tuatara I know I have this
next question comes from Alexa who asks
my name has recently been stolen by
Amazon do you have any suggestions on
how to cope I mean you you now live in a
Google home obviously like it just
happened you now are at Google household
and also you can never go to any of your
friends houses unless they are at Google
house order in fact just don't leave the
house cuz you could be like it's like
Alexa do we have any carrots in Alexa's
like I'll getcha carrots
I got a but they're on the way eight
pounds yeah oxo do you mind chopping up
the onions I'm sorry I can't do that yet
yet the scary saying yet why are they
always saying yeah oh you know where
they're saying yet no knives Alexa
you're not allowed knives knives not
robot Alexa normal person Alexa maybe we
should like I don't know stop letting
Amazon run our lives they've got a plan
we could all have together
[Applause]
yeah I mean we're you know the weird
thing is we really do have a choice
right now Alexa this isn't super
relevant to your question but we do have
a choice right now about what kind of
world do we want to live in do we want
to live in a world where there are not
many jobs and everything is easy and
automated and human connection is
dramatically decreased maybe I mean I'm
not and III and I think like certainly
that's where the tide of culture is
going and it might be the best way
there's there's one fan and the other
yeah we're like two they were like two
people who were like yeah that's what I
want which is fine and I get it by the
way like it is incredibly the idea of
two-hour delivery the idea of everything
on demand the idea of you know humans
not having to interact anymore with each
other which we have you know a very
mixed history of at best is appealing in
some ways but I do think that I I think
we need to acknowledge that much will be
lost in that process and not only for
people named Alexa but primarily for
people named Alexa this next question
comes from Mira who asks dear Hank and
John I ran into Hank before the show and
could only muster the courage to say hi
an incredibly crackly voice so my
question is when you meet someone you
really admire but don't want to bother
what do you say I'm pretty bad at this
so I can i I know how to do it from
having people have like done a really
good job with me like when they meet me
and Target and I'll be like that person
crushed it but when I when I do it I
have a 100 percent failure rate and like
like everybody else like I still think
that the people I had awkward
interactions with still think about me
and like are still worried about it and
I still want to apologize for it so like
I met Sherman Alexie a few years ago and
I like waited like a full 35 seconds he
was like who should I sign the book for
and I was like
and it was like many hours passed before
I finally said John in a questioning
voice as if I still wasn't sure and I
think about my guy it's one of the
things I think about like when I lie
awake at night like I bet Sherman Alexie
has let it go I bet it's not the first
time that somebody's been overwhelmed
you know thought it couldn't get all the
words out they wanted to say you know
etc I'm sure that it's fine
I'm sure he's good we did a bet he
doesn't think about it that much anymore
and I and by the way if we've ever had
an awkward encounter anybody in this
room if you and I have ever had an
awkward encounter I just want to say
right now we're good we're good
so this morning's Mira Mira we're good I
mean Hanks good you would hankers good
he didn't believe me he had to read it
he just would not I don't trust earth so
this morning I left the hotel because I
was like I need to get out of the hotel
room because I'm obsessed with this
stupid story that I'm not actually gonna
know anything about for several days but
I keep reading Twitter and I'm sick of
it and so I was like I'm gonna go walk
around the marina and I go walk around
the marina analyze we'd have to be the
bus until 9:30 and then I get a text at
9:10 and Jon's like where are you and I
look and it says 9:00 not 9:30 so I
start to book it back from the marina
just like running you know at 8 miles an
hour or whatever is my top speed is if I
take the under on that
six and uh
and I'm going as fast as I can back to
the hotel room and I get to the hotel
and the bus is on the left and I wave to
Brock ease and let him know I'm coming
our driver and I'm but I don't even
break my stride and there's a guy who
says are you and I said I can't I can't
I was like oh my god I just said I can't
I can't
what's he gonna think he's gonna tweet
about this I did I forgot about that
until just now and now yeah now I'm
gonna be the one thinking about that all
night long it's like I can't I can't
9:18 usually usually I gotta get my bags
usually it's the it's the person who is
the fan who makes it weird fine you
definitely made that weird you
definitely did that here's my advice
make it short
be friendly take take a picture ask to
take a picture if you want or get an
autograph or or anything sometimes it's
like how is this gonna end now we've
started the conversation and yeah is it
like do we just go until one of us has
to pee like what happens
hey can we get a picture and then it's
like of course you can't man yeah
picture that's like we did the thing and
then yeah and then no matter like you if
you're like me you're gonna spend the
next like three days like kind of like
hashing it through and thinking about
like I did this wrong it's okay he was
clearly running why did I try to stop
him he just yelled I can't it's okay
Hank's not mad at that person he's
correctly mad at himself this next
question comes from Emma who writes grad
school was stressing me out
should I open a bakery
oh my god Emma oh wow Emma I mean bad
news you are I'm a little worried you
might be romanticizing
the bakery business so I don't know
where you are but I don't know how
stressful grad school is but do you wake
up at 2:30 in the morning every morning
do you like then go to work by 3:00 so
that you can like you know start like
chopping the yeah sesame seeds I don't
know I don't really know what goes into
it they generally being very close to
very hot things that might hurt you and
then you also have employees and like
they might get hurt and they might
they're not gonna show up and you have
to call them and be like oh yeah what
were you up to last night but the breads
not gonna bake itself Trevor and
honestly Emma there's no way they're
gonna be as invested in your bakery idea
as you are right because like they're
there to cash a check ultimately like
they're they didn't like start out
wanting to open a bakery they started
out seeing a want ad and like this job
will do for now
Emma God yeah it's gonna be very
stressful also I've spent like two hours
in Portland and it seems to me that
there is like not a like huge shortage
of bakeries is there is there something
you can put into the baked goods that
will make it more desirable even even
that business seems somewhat saturated
it's pretty hard to think of a new baked
good you could put that into that they
haven't got already Emma running a
business is very stressful I do it all
the time and I'm not saying it's a bad
idea you could totally get into the
business business whatever the business
is but it's probably gonna I don't know
I don't know it's gonna be more
stressful it's going to be there it's
gonna be stressful in a way that you
like in a different way and maybe
better for you but like also you got to
read spreadsheets oh yeah god yeah it's
not just bacon also when I was so when I
was a bacon when I was in common
I don't know okay so no when I was in
college I have a story about this snake
they got the joke you didn't it's okay I
actually just realized the story is not
even that good let's just Rene asks dear
Hank and John where is your favorite
place in the whole world you ask of two
men who have been on the road for quite
a while who sleep in a different bed
every night of varying quality my bed my
bed my bed is my favorite place of all
it has my wife in it sometimes it as my
baby in it and then it will also
occasionally have my cat in it and it's
just one rectangle and has all my
favorite stuff that's yeah yeah I mean
that's pretty much how I feel but I was
actually gonna say the bus maybe I got
like a little bit of uh I don't know
what it is but every time I'm on the bus
I'm like yeah it's got a Nintendo switch
it's got like good people I like being
with we're on the move I've got a bunch
of beds yeah it's got eight beds Hank I
mean and of identical quality let's
answer some questions from our listeners
this first question comes from Julie who
writes Dear John and Hank I almost made
out with a boy at a Halloween party
I mean almost what happened how do you
almost make out with someone eight it's
like yeah like isn't it possible that
you did it almost make out with somebody
I don't know we're gonna move on to
courage that's not the question what do
I do if I run into him and don't
recognize his face
I mean definitionally if you don't
recognize his face you will treat him as
if he is a person you have not almost
made out with yeah yeah you're gonna the
good news Julie is that what you want to
do doesn't matter because you're gonna
do the only thing that you can do when
you don't recognize someone's face which
is treat them as a stranger so you just
have to be really kind and generous to
everyone you meet forever
the bad news is that really the question
is how do I live in a world where anyone
I meet might be someone I almost made
out with at a Halloween party in 2017
right for the rest of your life yeah
yeah I mean I I feel like I am in that
boat I went to college like I yeah like
I'm in that situation and I've been able
to navigate the world fairly effectively
do you have a question yeah this next
question comes from Brian who asks dear
Hank and John I am a father who is
trying to connect with my daughter she
loves your book and has watched all of
your videos how can I be a cool dad and
talk about you without watching a
hundred hours of video good news and bad
news
it's more than a hundred hours of video
and it's all great
there's also a podcast comes from Amy
who writes dear John and Hank I'm the
new cat and he is fantastic however he
is way too good at killing things I put
a bell on his collar but that has not
slowed him down it's just given like
every animal in your yard a new last
noise they hear any dubious advice is
greatly appreciated there is a dead
snake in my living room yeah so your cat
is made of knives and it's a very good
cat and if you want it to not kill
things you have to keep it inside and
which the cat is gonna not like you just
gotta weigh your cat be a cat man sorry
that's what I got inside for my cat
safety and also the safety of all the
lovely animals in my yard John yes next
question comes from Ryan who asks what
is your favorite DC character in wine
with deep sea DC DC character yeah oh
I'm completely fascinated by this Paul
Manafort business like the
he has three passports he travels
internationally under fake names that's
amazingly had 30 passport his email is a
morning line is very compelling his
email password respond
0:07 it's gold it's all gold I am not
about finding the John McCain's story
line breaks no there's so many companies
he carried three straight hammers the DC
Universe is so amazing it's big it's
gotten really bizarre if I was the
Marvel Universe out of literally you can
bat John I do I want to congratulate you
on that joke it was amazing thank you
this question comes from Jessica who
writes please answer this debate which
movie is stranger not to have seen Star
Wars or Goonies
Jessica respectfully I mean I let me
rephrase your question which movie is
stranger not to have seen Star Wars or
literally any other movie and Star Wars
is still weirder Goonies is a great
movie it is an important movie people
should see it it's not Star Wars there's
next question comes from Danielle who
asks dear Hank and John when did you
first feel successful I think it was
third grade I got I got a spelling test
and they there was a star like I think
there was like more than one star and I
gotten stars before but I didn't know
that you get like two possibly three
like there was one of those normal like
cut out sparkly stars but then there was
another was like you did great star next
to it that was like a different whole
different class of star and I was like
oh man I've killed it on this
that was that for me it was in 11th
grade I was on my high school's academic
decathlon team academic I don't know if
you're familiar with a government
decathlon but the rules are that the you
have you have 3a students we have GPAs
above like 3.75 3 B students whose GPA
are above 3.0 but below 3.75 and then
you have 3 C students whose GPS are
below 3.0 and those those are your stars
really because everybody has good a
students but I was a C student and I
went to the Alabama State Academic
Decathlon tournament and I I don't want
to brag but I crushed it I finished
second overall behind one of my
classmates another second in the C
student category yeah of course
da
Conte Hank yeah second overall in the C
student category including like a bronze
medal in both economics and math which I
knew nothing about and I've never I've
honestly never felt that good again ya
know I brought up the third grade thing
because like it literally feels the same
inside of my brain when like an another
cool thing happens but as like getting
and I do remember very clearly that
second star its success as a moment it
is not a permanent thing you don't get
to it's not like something you install
in your brain it's something that you
get and then you're like okay well and
then it evaporates and then you crave
more and and it never never it never is
a thing that you I sort of like always
thought that I would reach a point where
I was like and I'm happy now that didn't
come from that didn't come from like
what normal people would call success it
came from like loving people and people
liking me and having a good family that
I enjoy in a good place that I like and
good friends that I like that's yep
success rules and it isn't a real true
it's not sexy but it's true that this
next question comes from Dana who asks
why do the clouds stay still even while
we rotate so fast
oh man imagine if they did in yeah oh
god imagine how nauseating it would be
to look up in the skies moving in like
250,000 miles per hour
I mean the problem is that like the sky
at that point is also like the air
around you and that's enough like fast
enough to remove your skin and thing
like II vets that's bad that would be
real bad like all the buildings would go
yeah no you just float you just yeah you
you'd be toast you'd be toast yeah yeah
yeah so the situation is on the bottom
part of the atmosphere which is the
earth there's friction so there is like
molecules of air and there's also all
the ground and mountains and then
buildings and stuff on the upper part of
the atmosphere there's nothing to rub
against it's just space so all the
atmosphere spins with the earth that's
bit it wasn't funny sorry
great this question comes from Alexandra
who asks dear John and Hank what is your
Hogwarts house no why did you say it
that way ah I keep I keep bumping around
I need it free consorting had to tell me
like I can't decide for myself Who I am
that's like the whole literal hardest
thing that we all have to do is people
did you do Potter more I did what did
it's Slytherin oh yeah I know you can
kind of see it I can see it a little
it's funny like now the I would never
have thought it but now that you say it
I get it but I don't know I think it's a
little bit of like a harry potter
situation where the sorting hat puts put
goes on your head and it's like this guy
is interesting he contains multitudes
what if like my like my heart is
Gryffindor in my head is Ravenclaw and
like but my gut bacteria like my
microbiome is Slytherin yeah then I mean
your Slytherin that's how it works man
your gut in the end like the bacteria
that colonize you have so much say in
what you consider to be yourself but
we're not here to talk about that are
you actually in a way we are if that's
what the book is about but I'm not in
this bit I am a Hufflepuff and very
proud of the song
this next question comes from
[Music]
I'm not a very good reader of
handwriting and I also would argue that
you did not make it easy for me
maybe Gemelli Dear John and Hank if you
could be any character in a book which
would it be and why
I would argue that most characters and
books have way too much going on like
like they don't write books about very
relaxed people I want like I was one
right you know ever read like a book
where it's like I went on vacation and
it was great then I came home I felt
like more relaxed but also has a little
bit like why do I do this job again and
then the book ends that that's the book
I want to live inside you know the book
where like you go to Jamaica for eight
days and everything's good you hang out
with your spouse who you like not a lot
of novels like that oh oh I would be
like the guy in the castle the knight
with the washboard abs and the like long
flowing hair and the rippling pecs and
everything
tell me more about your rippling Pat
what are they that's that's why that
that because that is an awesome
narrative arc to enjoy like you get to
be in you get to know you're not gonna
die
because it's a romance novel so you get
to like be in the ancient past not
having to worry about like bacterial
infections or gangrene and you get the
girl like you have a great fulfilling
wonderful romance after what is a pretty
easy obstacle to overcome
that is 100% this question comes from
Matthew who asks how do you learn to do
the things you don't want to do because
they aren't fun because you can't you
don't like nobody's good at things at
first and so you get good at things that
you enjoy doing so you do them and
you're like I got better because that
was fun but then there are the things
that just aren't and you have to get
good at them anyway even though every
time you get better
you don't like it it's bad every time
yeah for me it's um spreadsheets
I love spreadsheets
[Applause]
I'll uh I mean I need to start
appreciating them correctly oh I mean
that's my advice what every year when I
send my tax spreadsheet to my accountant
she emails me back and she's like how do
how do you do this because she's like
you treat Excel like it's Microsoft Word
like you have written a Word document
inside of a spreadsheet format I just
think it's so like at that moment where
you like it the equation I mean you're
like highlight the cells and it's like
any like you just did all that math for
me I love that do it again I was doing a
bunch of calculations for all of our
YouTube channels for it to see like our
ad placement rates and I was just like
but that's not the question how do you
do things that you don't that you don't
use God get into it you gotta be like
spreadsheets
maybe it's amazing maybe I shouldn't
hate that's actually pretty good advice
like I think a lot of things in life are
a matter of attention and if you can pay
the right kind of attention to it you
can be like oh yeah this may be like
maybe this is there's something in this
for me that I can get into like I
remember recently I was on a walk with
my daughter and she picked up a pinecone
and she was like dad look at this
pinecone I picked it up and I looked at
it I was like yeah I mean Alice's
pinecone you know like there's a ton of
them like an actual ton of them in our
in our backyard and she was like no dad
look at this pinecone I start looking at
it and I was like oh wow this is amazing
actually like it's just a level of
attention like when you start to look at
a pinecone you're like man that is a lot
of symmetry this is how did that tree
make this and then drop it in the hopes
that in the future it can become a
different tree it's kind of beautiful
and amazing so just pay that kind of
attention try to get that like Alice
slash stoner approach to the world
hey let's answer a couple more questions
before we get to the all-important news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon this first
question comes from the next question
comes from anonymous how do you feel
about Taco Bell I have very few I could
drop that opinion yes yes yes it makes
me or by when I was in high school even
when I was in high school of being oh
you know that should be their slogan
nearby I was in high school a Taco Bell
bean burrito which they still have was
25 yeah yeah we got some 30 something's
over there and it was a night every day
and I got I would be get to me burritos
and I'd be out two quarters and then
they raised the price to 35 cents and I
was I'm so angry like my first like if I
had had Twitter and I would have been
all over that one what a dramatic brazen
crease it's merely clearly a 33%
increase okay just step it up slowly 28
cents
you know 31 cents 10 10% price increases
that makes sense I agree with you
completely
but that doesn't matter anymore because
Hank and I no longer high opinion about
Taco Bell right
two methods nearby everybody's always
talking about like what Taco Bell does
to your digestive system I have a very
fragile digestive system I don't find
the time develop sets my stomach at all
okay you talk about Louise in the house
okay you vivec doesn't see that gradual
digestive system in the sense that you
have a very fragile digestive system but
you only eat like eighteen hour old hot
dogs from the gas station that we
stopped at on tour and then you're fine
I don't really understand how it works
no okay I'll tell you I'll tell you what
I do know about this is this is a tip
that no one asked for about digestive
health that was something that one ever
said to me but the main thing that helps
me is to not eat a lot all at once like
that night we had nachos yeah I was
wrecked in the morning
yeah and it wasn't that I had nachos is
that I had like a thousand calories of
nachos and ten o'clock at night want to
take me over for sure I don't think you
know what a thousand calories of nachos
look like yeah
I made my main tip for people who have
irritable bowel things is like 300
calories at a time it just like keep
going and everything everything turns
out much better in the end
brought to you by Hades fragile
digestion system
thanks gradual digestive system lots of
tips today's podcast is also brought to
you by the DC Universe is coming home
this podcast is also brought to you by
the herd of cows at bat out packet the
easy there does they milk them straight
into the I school I that sounds gross I
take it back this podcast is also
brought to you by Hanks bed Hanks bed it
contains everything that Hank loves
except what about me it's so not invited
and of course this podcast is brought to
you by the movie Goonies the movie
Gerdes optional alright Hank this our
last question comes from Jonathan and he
asks is outer space cold depends on
where you are right because if you're in
the Sun then no
that's a great point Hank I hadn't
thought of it that way but right if
you're like inside a star super warm
yeah in fact weirdly enough the the area
just outside of the Sun is much hotter
than the surface of the Sun oh cool so
when I approach it yeah I'll never sleep
so when I finally get there I'll be like
oh that's that's better huh so warm
there for a minute yeah so the weird
thing about outer space is that it is
mostly very cold but heat is a function
of not is a function of like the energy
and molecules but there aren't a lot of
molecules so you could be if you like
suddenly are in space you won't feel
cold you will feel we will feel dead
substantially before you feel cold
because yeah because there isn't it
there aren't enough molecules to
actually suck the heat away from your
body it will eventually happen you
eventually become cold as time goes on
and Wes you're like like if you're in
the Sun you'll be being hit by all the
high energy particles that are currently
hitting the earth like all that
radiation heats up the Space Shuttle
just like it heats up the earth so it
all depends on where you are so if
you're in the shadow of a body or if
you're in like interstellar space it's
cold but there isn't enough space
there's enough stuff in this space to
actually cool you off very fast well I
mean that's vaguely encouraging right so
whenever you see like like frosty bodies
in space like soon after like that and
they're like lit exit the spacecraft and
then suddenly they're just freeze that's
not how it works you you well I mean you
do die alright Hank what is the news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon so they have
released some of the final designs of
the Mars 2020 Rover John uh-huh
so this is the next Rover after
Curiosity it's based on curiosity very
similar design but curiosity's got I
think 17 cameras this bad boys got 23
and a lot of a lot of those cameras that
were previously acity cameras have been
upgraded they so curiosity it has to
take pictures of like its wheels and its
surroundings to make sure it doesn't run
over anything that's gonna hurt it and
keep keep track everything and those
cameras used to be like really small
crappy cameras that would take a bunch
of pictures and they'd stitch them all
together back at home and it would take
a little extra time and it slows down
the mission now that is putting nice
like 23 megapixel cameras full color
down there which is gonna allow us to
move faster they can take pictures while
the Rovers moving which they couldn't
before the big problem with that is that
they act like those bigger files have to
get back to earth for us to do to figure
out like what's going on and there's
sort of there's a data bottleneck like
the Internet to Mars is pretty slow
turns out so they are they are both
trying to figure out like we need better
cameras but also we need to figure out
how to better utilize the existing
network of communication satellites that
we have around Mars to beam that
information back to earth
as frequently and without interruption
with it with like fewer interruptions so
that they can keep keep up with that but
23 cameras on Mars 2020 Rover which will
hopefully be launching in 2020 and will
have a second freakin minivan on Mars
it's pretty cool pretty cool well the
news from America's favorite third tier
English soccer team is terrible AFC
Wimbledon today played in the caribou
Cup which is like the Football League
trophy it matters not at all unless you
like make it to the semi-finals which we
won't so it's not an issue and we
especially won't because we lost we lost
a Luton Town which by the way is the
same team that we beat to make it back
into the Football League to the fourth
tier of English soccer and a penalty
shootout where Seb brown saved two
penalties one of the greatest moments
really in human history and but we lost
two to one the the one goal was scored
by Lyle Taylor the the Montserrat E and
Messi the greatest football striker in
the history of the nation of Montserrat
great great goalie scored and you
couldn't help but be hopeful accept that
then Lyle Taylor came off with an injury
which is
very bad because AFC Wimbledon have
scored 10 goals this season and Lisle
Taylor has scored five of them so we
just we have the lowest goal total of
any team in the league and we just lost
half of our goals for goodness knows how
long so hashtag crisis hashtag panic
hashtag Elon Musk just like all we need
is like a hundred grand I know you're
thinking you got some resources green
well my wife said no she said that our
philanthropy focuses on global health
and poverty and she struggled to see how
it was directly related to either Hank
thank you for Pollock with me thanks to
all of you for listening and as they say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome and now it's over thank you for
listening and I will remind you again
since now you're no longer listening to
a podcast you can go to pod calm calm to
see if maybe you want to get your genes
to Seattle December 9th and 10th or if
you're already there I don't know I
don't even know I'm not sure if I meant
genes like a.j or jeans with a G you
will definitely bring your G genes those
come no matter what but you'll probably
also bring your J genes I just didn't
want to say but okay that's what it was
I decided but now I've said but so
anyway dear Hank it's the coupon code
for $10 off we're doing a live to your
Hank and John they're a bunch of other
amazing stuff is also happening you can
find out about that stuff at pod calm
calm it's just an opportunity for people
to celebrate and discuss and love
podcasts together thank you for
listening to me ramble I hope you
enjoyed listening to this was a bit of a
pain in the butt to put together but I'm
glad that I did it because I got to save
some of the really wonderful moments
that we had on tour and thank you if you
came to see us on tour we had such an
amazing time and I am so thankful to
everybody who came out I mean we just
had such a good time it was like it was
crazy to be on the road together for
almost a month straight and you know
it's it's really special to have an
opportunity to spend that kind of time
your brother so thanks John and I can't
wait to do our next live dear Hank and
John and December at pod con and a long
one too it's just so fun to answer
questions from the people who are
actually in the room with you and to see
their reactions and they connect a
little bit more so thanks to everybody
who came out thanks to John and thanks
to everybody who's come into pod con I
cannot wait to see you thank you for
supporting this first year thing it can
be really hard to make a first year
thing work so everybody who's doing that
you are the best thanks so much for
listening